Salut ! aujourd'hui on est  dimanche c'est le
jour des explications et je vais vous
expliquer comment devenir invisible !
Evidemment que non quoi je peux pas
vous expliquer ça pour une simple
raison
c'est pas que je ne sais pas faire c'est  que c'est
un secret beaucoup trop lourd à porter
Peut-être je l'expliquerai à la 366e vidéo.
On est dimanche matin, je dis un
petit peu n'importe quoi mais surtout
vous êtes en train de vous réveiller
dans votre lit tranquillement en train
de regarder la vidéo et je vous vois,
je vous vois car j'ai piraté de la
caméra de votre téléphone parce que
je sais que vous êtes sur votre
téléphone portable
je sais beaucoup trop de choses !
aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre
à deviner à quel prénom pense qu'une
personne.  Evidemment il n'y aura pas de
démonstration parce que sans personne,
je ne peux pas faire la démonstration,
mais vous m'avez déjà vu faire des
choses similaires dans pas mal de
vidéos, je vais vous  mettre  une petite fiche
avec une vidéo un peu correspondante.
Comment faire ça ?
alors qu'on soit bien clair je vous
apprends une méthode très soft, la
plus soft possible
c'est, on va dire, l'espèce de première
étape, le premier palier.
Libre à vous après de le complexifier dans la mise en
scène, ce qui m'intéresse que vous
reteniez c'est l'idée, et comment on va
interpréter un signe chez quelqu'un.
Je vais prendre une mise en scène pour
l' exemple et je vais vous donner deux ou
trois idées différentes pour aller déjà un peu plus loin.
Imaginons vous êtes dans une soirée il
y a une vingtaine de personnes.Vous vous
proposez de faire l'expérience sur
une des personnes, elle doit se placer
devant vous et  fermer les yeux.
Vous lui demandez vraiment de fermer les yeux de
jouer le jeu c'est très important sinon ça
ne fonctionnera pas et vous lui demandez
de se détendre. C'est pas de l'hypnose,
mais une petite suggestion serait quand
même pas mal donc vous pouvez
baisser la voix d'un demi-ton, parler un
petit peu plus lentement tout en
essayant de le rassurer en lui demandant
de se détendre et d'expirer trois fois
très longuement. Ca a juste comme but de détendre la personne et de créer un petit
lien, une petite connexion avec vous pour
vraiment qu'elle rentre dans le jeu et
qu'elle fasse tout ce que vous lui
demandez dans son esprit.
A partir de ce moment-là vous lui
demandez de penser au prénom d'une
des personnes présentes dans la soirée.
Donc en termes de texte, ça pourrait donner :
"A partir de maintenant, pense au prénom
d'une des personnes qui est présente dans la soirée,"
"tu y penses,  tu y penses vraiment, tu vois
ce prénom dans ta tête,"
"et tu l'entends, tu le répètes dans ta tête,"
"et tu le vois s'inscrire en toutes
lettres devant toi, tu visualises bien les lettres une par une....."
C'est la première phase.
Deuxième phase vous allez l'emmener
dans un monde imaginaire, vous allez
expliquer à la personne qu'elle est en
train de marcher dans un chemin boueux.
Elle a de la boue jusqu'aux genoux en fait
c'est très très dur d'avancer.
donc vous lui expliquez ça et vous lui demandez
de se visualiser en train de marcher, vraiment en train d'avancer, et
en train de regarder ses jambes
lutter contre la boue.
Ce qui donnerait à peu près :
"A partir maintenant j'ai besoin que tu te concentres, que tu t'imagines en train de "
"marcher. Mais tu es en train de marcher
dans un chemin très boueux, "
"tu as de la boue jusqu'aux chevilles, même un petit peu plus haut, au-dessus du tibia, "
"juste en dessous du genou, "
"mais c'est une boue épaisse, une boue un peu dense, "
"et tu vas avoir du mal à avancer dedans,
je veux vraiment que tu imagines dans ta"
"tête que tu es en train d'avancer, dans
cette boue, "
"en luttant, c'est très compliqué, "
"Mais tu avances quand même.
Et tu regardes mentalement tes "
" jambes, pour voir "
" si tu ne te prends rien et si t'arrives à
avancer. Tout le temps mentalement, "
" quoi qu'il se passe et quoi que je dise, tu
avances mentalement en regardant tes jambes. "
Ca c'était la deuxième phase.
on va passer à la troisième phase, où
vous aller lui donner une information
très précise qui va vous permettre
d'avoir la bonne indication. Vous allez
lui expliquer que vous allez dire toutes
les lettres de l'alphabet, lentement. Et
au moment où vous allez dire la première lettre
du prénom de la personne à qui il
ou elle pense, alors un grand
escalier, un escalier géant sortira de la
boue,
montera, et en haut des escaliers il
aura la personne à qui il pensait et
mentalement il va regarder  cette personne pour aller le rejoindre.
Ce qui donnerait, dans les grandes lignes :
" Alors que t'es en train d'avancer, d'avancer dans la boue je vais épeler "
" toutes les lettres de l'alphabet, une par une et lentement. "
" Au moment où je prononcerai "
" la première lettre du prénom de la
personne que tu as choisie,  tu visualiseras "
" spontanément instantanément et
volontairement un 'escalier géant, qui "
" sortira de la boue. "
" Il fait quelques mètres de haut et en haut de cet escalier, "
" il ya la personne à qui tu penses. Quand
cet escalier sortira, tu regarderas "
" cette personne là  dans les yeux, en haut de l'escalier. Retiens bien :  quand je prononce  "
" la lettre de la personne a qui tu es en
train de penser, l'escalier sort, se lève "
" avec la personne à qui tu penses en haut
et tu le regardes dans les yeux. "
" C'est parti, maintenant. "
" A........B.......C....... "
Et vous votre taf' pendant cette
période-là,
c'est de focaliser uniquement sur ses
paupières.
Quand on a les yeux fermés, quand on a
les paupières closes,  les mouvements
oculaires sont quand même décelables.
Ne vous inquiétez pas je me rapproche de la caméra.
Vous avez dû voir nettement mes yeux
bouger derrière la paupière. Ce qui
se passe, dans le conditionnement que
vous avez mis en place, la personne
regarde vers le bas. Ce qu'on fait
mentalement, on le fait aussi
physiquement donc les yeux sont
vraiment vers le bas. Au moment où la
personne va s'imaginer l'escalier sortir
de la boue,
avec la personne tout en haut de l'escalier. Vous lui avez demandé de regarder dans
les yeux, directement dans les yeux de la
personne mentalement, donc
instantanément mentalement la personne
va s'imaginer lever la tête et lever
les yeux, le regard vers les yeux de l'autre personne,  mentalement
mais aussi physiquement.
Ce qui va donner quelque chose comme ça,
a peu près, j'espère qu'on me voit bien parce que, du coup les yeux fermés
j'ai du mal à cadrer
mais ça fait à peu près ça :
Elle est en train de marcher, comme ça,
elle regarde, elle regarde et là il ya un
escalier et elle regarde en haut. Dès que vous avez vu les yeux se lever vous avez la
première lettre. En général dans une soirée où il y a une  vingtaine de personnes, la première
lettre suffit à savoir à qui
le spectateur est en train de penser. Si il
vous faut une deuxième lettre beaucoup et
faire redescendre d'escalier, avancer, faire
la même méthodologie avec la deuxième
lettre. En fait, vous faites ce que vous voulez, moi il y a un truc que j'aime bien faire, j'écris
une liste de vingt-six stars sur un
papier. Le truc que je dis pas, et je
mélange pour pas que ça se voit,
c'est que les noms de famille de chacune
de ces stars commencent par une autre lettre,
donc il y a des groupes de musique, il y a des chanteurs, il y a des acteurs, ce ne
sont que des gens populaires. En vrai je
n'en ai pas 26 d'ailleurs, j'en ai  24 et
je lui demande de choisir une star dedans, et je fais toute la même procédure.
Comme ça, juste en trouvant la première lettre, BAM,
je peux trouver directement la personne
à qui elle pense.
Pour la révélation vous pouvez l'écrire sur
un bout de papier, lui faire ouvrir les
yeux, ensuite lu faire dire et faire voir le bout de papier à tout le monde, vous pouvez
aussi, ça c'est drôle, pendant que la
personne a les yeux fermés, mettre la
personne à qui il pense devant,
de lui demander, les yeux fermés, de dire
à qui il  pense, de claquer des doigts,
d'ouvrir les yeux, la personne est en face, ça match.
Ce que  je voulais vraiment vous
expliquer aujourd'hui c'était un tips (indice)
pour avoir la première lettre ou les
premières lettres, et pouvoir déduire la fin du prénom. C'est une première
étape dans l'escalier des explications de
mentalisme. Escalier, escalier !  Vous avez vu,
j'ai bossé le texte quand même.
J'espère vraiment que ça vous aura plu, que vous
allez vous entraîner à le faire.Là je
parle de prénoms, ça aurait pu être des légumes,
ça aurait pu être des films, c'aurait pu être ce que vous voulez en fait.
L'important c'est de
retenir la méthode. Essayez de
construire quelque chose à vous,
quelque chose de bluffant, quelque chose
qui vous plaît,
dans votre présentation à vous, dans
votre univers à vous. Et commencez à
exploiter cette première méthode.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette explication du
dimanche, c'est un plaisir de commencer
cette journée avec vous, si cette
explication vous a plu vous pouvez m'encourager en laissant un petit pouce en l'air du dimanche
qui fait tellement plaisir !
Et en cette magnifique journée
où je crois qu'il  va pleuvoir partout en
france, vous pouvez vous abonner à la
chaîne et partager la vidéo ça mettra
des petits rayon de soleil dans les
écrans des gens. Parce que le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an, depuis le 1er janvier donc à demain
à 17 heures, TCHAO !